now to a fairy tale come back for Brandy
turns out the glass slipper still fits
only 18 was on set of her Cinderella
return
[Music]
I told you this you literally changed my
life doing that movie changed his mind
wait what's your name
Cinderella the love is so real between
Brandy and Paolo Montalban who's now
King Charming the two on-screen
lovebirds are reuniting after more than
25 years for the upcoming Disney plus
original movie Descendants the rise of
the red we both have said it doesn't
feel like any time has passed no
it's like being around family
um and we came up with the perfect word
surreal time does not pass when I look
at Brandon oh neither Junior doesn't
want to look at you
1997 Cinderella star Whoopi Goldberg as
the queen Bernadette Peters as the evil
stepmother and of course Whitney Houston
played Brandy's fairy godmother
the world is full of zanies and food at
that time Brandi was just 18 years old
Paulo was 24 and they have the sweetest
memories of working together on set I
remember Watson with you yeah I loved
how you just led me and made me feel so
comfortable because I was really
uncomfortable with walking really
because I was I was terrified that it
was going to step on your feet the whole
time and I'm pretty sure that I did and
I just love singing with you it was just
our voices together just it just was so
magical yeah it really was
[Music]
we had such great great memories for
that time huh we did we were kids we
were
[Music]
thank you